a total shoulder replacement is a
surgical procedure to replace your
shoulder joint
your main shoulder joint is made up of
two bones the top or head of your upper
arm bone called the humerus
and part of your shoulder blade or
scapula called the glenoid
it's called a ball and socket joint
because the ball-like head of your
humerus fits into the cup-like socket of
the glenoid
a total shoulder replacement is often
done to ease pain from shoulder
conditions
such as arthritis
or severe bone fractures
your joint will be replaced with an
artificial joint called a prosthesis it
has two parts that look like the bones
of the shoulder joint a ball with a stem
and a socket
a total shoulder replacement will begin
with an incision over your shoulder
joint
after reaching your shoulder joint your
surgeon will remove the damaged head of
your humerus
then a hole will be made inside your
humerus
next the socket of the glenoid will be
reshaped
then holes will be drilled for the
socket part of the prosthesis
your surgeon will place the socket part
of the prosthesis into this area
and the ball part of the prosthesis will
be placed into the hole in the humerus
finally your surgeon will slide the ball
of the prosthesis into the new socket
at the end of the procedure the incision
will be closed with staples or stitches
after the procedure you will need to
wear a sling on your arm for a few weeks
while your shoulder heals
for more information about a total
shoulder replacement talk to your health
care provider
you